foreign
[Music]
thank you all for coming
um so I don't have my notes so I'm going
to do my best
um because I don't I can't extend the
displays on this computer but I think
I'll do okay
um so this presentation
um
first of all let me start off I'm Louis
cavan I'm a research manager at the
Consumer Finance Protection Bureau and
I'm supposed to say this I am not a
representative of the US government I am
just myself right now I don't know if
you can tell but I'm not
um the point of this talk
um is to help data analysts with words
um and I think words are actually super
important for data analysts if you've
ever communicated with a leader in your
organization you'll know that a lot of
communication about data actually flows
through words and that you know getting
good at words is really going to
differentiate you as a data person so
the first part of this talk is about
identifying situations when you're going
to need more words
um right so that's part one part two is
how to make words a little bit easier to
work with so this is focusing on a
couple things but also when you want to
actually generate text it's going to
give you some tips a few tips to sort of
help you generate text so that's the
structure of this talk let's get rolling
all right so chapter one when do you
need more words
um so this is probably the most familiar
diagram at the conference everyone's
seen this like way too many times it's
kind of funny that I put in here
um but this document really captures a
lot about the data products process the
process of creating data products but I
think it leaves that one really
important thing
you're actually in the the middle of
that cycle right
um and you're doing stuff like there you
are hands on hips
um so you're in the middle of the cycle
and you're actually doing stuff
um and gaining context as you that cycle
sort of spins around you right you're
actually learning about the data
learning about the analysis learning
about what the goals are so you might do
some stuff like this you might look at
the application that generates the data
you might read a survey instrument you
might talk to application users
you might read the data documentation if
you're extremely lucky
you might read relevant research or talk
to experts that know about how and why
the data was generated
in my opinion that's all statistics and
data science too that's all important
stuff and knowing about the context of
your data is how you don't make really
stupid errors so it's super important
and it's something that I think we don't
emphasize enough actually
all right so you did your analysis you
got all this context and it's time to
communicate this is the fun part R's
really good at this
right I don't want to knock on
dashboards too much
um you know I've built a lot of
dashboards actually in my life
um and you know this dashboard actually
might be fine for someone it's just what
I got when I Googled the busiest
dashboard or something like that
um so you know I think that dashboards
are fine but when you reach for a
communication tool
um you know you want to think a little
bit before you grab something that's
very visually dense or has a lot of
moving parts
so before you communicate
you want to think about your audience
um and so the rest of this talk or the
rest of this first part is going to be a
little bit how about how you think about
your audience
you want to bring people Along on your
journey
um
so I you know
people need to be brought along and a
great first question to ask is you know
how much of that context I built up
during my analysis does my audience
share
you know if they don't share the context
it's going to be a difficult Journey
right it's like how much do you need to
pack to get that person to the
destination you want them to go to
all right so I have a couple of limit
cases here examples from my own work so
earlier this year I wrote a report to
Congress it's like required by law and
it's about credit reporting consumer
complaints
um it's got six charts in it two tables
yeah okay cool started in our markdown
and it's got 50 pages of context
Congress is one limited case Congress
needs like a lot of stuff
um they need detailed explanations of
all the fields and all the key terms
they need to know about the data
collection process and they need to know
about like the the law that governs the
data collection and all that context
um I actually have a JD so like that
part helped me here
um but the Congress needs a lot of stuff
so that's like one limit case
another limit case is your immediate
team right so a ways back I made this
dashboard took me a day
um got three charts in it six kpis less
than paragraph of text beautiful right
me and my team tracking something
the labels are kind of terse so I don't
really describe the kpis because like
there are kpis we know what they are
um and you know like the data elements
are just name what they are in the
system right so this is the other
extreme you're likely going to be
somewhere in the middle right but these
are the two limit cases so I have
another example that I think oh so just
to kind of sum up that idea less shared
context means more context words are
going to be in your data product
more shared context uh means you can
kind of include less context in your
product but you should still document it
because you might forget other people
might work on it so it's kind of a
seesaw there you can go does it end up
in the documentation or does it end up
in the in the data product
so here's another example
um moving from an internal set of tools
to something external I like this
example because it's the same data
presented to two different audiences
so the internal tool is an interactive
Tableau dashboard
it's got like a lot of charts dozens of
charts
um you know the table is good for that
and then the you know like the other
example the field names just correspond
to the system names
um it's kind of a typical kpi type
dashboard for your team but when this
team went to sort of report out on this
stuff
um you know they started with this
um and they kind of just started to
repurpose it for external communication
you know but we were going to actually
share this with banks and we're sort of
assessing their performance and I knew
when I got sort of thrown into helping
them that this document was meant to
travel it wasn't just going to go to the
person who works on this stuff every day
they were going to give it to their
supervisor and maybe their supervisor
would give it to someone else and I
probably won't go to the board of
directors but like it could go travel
and so the context had to travel with
the document so we have this much
simpler version so there's only three
simple static charts one kind of gives
you a Time series of your performance
one gives you your average or you know
each one gives you your average and then
Compares you against your peers and
against some sort of overall performance
so that's pretty nice
um some of the charts from the internal
dashboard are actually sentences and
paragraphs now
um so
um
the names are all also defined in an
introduction you know a sentence is
actually if you just like tell someone
what the chart means that's actually
denser than a chart right so in some
places we want to do that stuff
um I also you know included different
texts depending on thresholds and other
stuff right so some of these sentences
and paragraphs didn't really apply to
some of these companies and so we
thresholded it and they just don't
appear in the document so it doesn't
like bloat and bloat and blow so that's
an example of moving from internal to
external
summarize this with some key factors the
biggest one is external right if they're
outside your org they don't have any of
your context likely but even within your
org you can think about levels of
externality right you know there's your
media team and then there's consensus
concentric circles and as you kind of
move further away from your team you
need to be adding more context in
another key factor is if you're kind of
dealing with a less technical audience
um less technical audiences mean you
can't use shortcuts that you might use
when you're communicating with a
technical audience like you're not just
going to present an Roc curve to your
executive and say hey look my model's
really good look because they're not
going to get that right
um so you you have to think about adding
more context in for those folks
decision makers are important because
they actually need context to trust what
you're telling them if they don't have
appropriate context they're not going to
trust you and they're going to project
your findings even if you're right right
you can pound the table law you want but
they need enough context to trust you
and I've had this happen to me
pretty disappointing honestly when
you're like look it works it's great and
they're like I don't know what this is
even right so you have to give them that
appropriate context
time crunched is actually kind of
counter-intuitive in a way right time
crunch people like you want to give them
as little as possible in some ways but
you're only going to get them one time
right so those time crunch people have
one shot and if they don't walk away
with the context that's necessary to
understand this they'll either
misinterpret it not interpret it or
forget about it right so those time
crunch people are important too so those
are some key factors when thinking about
this question of like what should I
build how much context do I need to put
in it for my audience all right
chapter 2 how to make words a little bit
easier
all right I'm done guys that's it
actually now I'm done
um
not really I actually have some tips
um
so my dips are just three kind of simple
things use some templates
use design resources and then partner up
um all right let's start with the first
one
so the context here is you're generating
text
um I don't know if you've ever generated
a document with a lot of text what
happens is your dot your environment
just gets littered with variables
there's all kinds of different variables
some of these documents I put together
you know 10 15 pages you know you've
computed 10 different means they all
have different names and when you make a
mistake debugging is annoying and hard
and so what you can do is actually add a
language engine that will allow you to
put templates in your markdown document
and then fill them with data this is a
really simple language
um
um like really simple function you can
just add at the top of your markdown
file it's it's a Knitter engine here
um and this works in quarto I just did
it right that works
um so you add this this is using whisker
which is uses mustache templates I'll
talk about that in just one second
um options code that's just the stuff
that's in your code block so you put
your template in there and then as an
argument you supply some data and then
it will render and make something nice
for you
um you could do it with glue too right
so here it is with glue basically the
same function you need more stuff for
glue this would be like a lot quite a
bit longer if I were to really put this
together for glue but just so you can
see the basics are the same it this
still works but there's stuff you want
to do
um
all right so here's an example of just
that concept of of taking your namespace
or using a list as a namespace so that
you don't
basically end up cluttering your
namespace so I'm generating one sentence
here and there's one two three four five
or so six variables there's a bunch of
variables just for one sentence right
and what I like to do is when I have a
document with some structure in it like
a section I'll have a list and I'll pack
all the variables for that section into
the list that's named the same and then
my environment stays like relatively
pretty debugging gets easier and like my
mental load is a developer doesn't sort
of go Haywire completely right and so
then when you go to do this it's
actually pretty simple
you have right here this is a mustache
template a really simple one
um mustache is great it has some other
it's a logicless template so it's it's
very it's almost like markdown in a way
but you can add some basically data
dependent stuff that will like make
stuff appear or not appear
um there's a few other nice little
features
um but it kind of just works so there's
the data filling it in the sentence now
exists and there's a glue version you
need some post-processing on glue to
make it not have codes and stuff the
real function I use is longer but I
didn't want to go into all that detail
um so that's tip one I think it's pretty
helpful
um and you know if you do more of this
stuff especially when you're generating
a lot of text it's super helpful
tip two use existing design resources
um design is like super duper important
when you're
um when you're making a document that
you want people to read you need
consistency and you need signposting to
make the document useful
um and you know I am kind of took a
weird path to being a researcher and
data analyst I've got a degree in
African history and a degree and a JD so
I spent like 30ish years trying to make
other kinds of good documents
um so some of this stuff is is natural
to me but I think it should be more
natural to data analysts as well so
someone at your org has probably thought
about those issues that signposting that
consistency and they have resources for
you so you should steal them basically
um
so
it's almost as easy as this right so you
have in your yaml
um a reference stock
the actual package comes with a
reference dock you look at that
reference nut it shows you all the
styles that you need
um and actually
um Porto has some surprisingly good
actually documentation on word Styles if
you if you need some documentation on it
um and so then you can either adjust the
Styles yourself or you can actually copy
and paste Styles between documents so if
you have a nice reference document you
can go ahead and use that
um great so this is what it looks like
when you use it it's just like any other
pandok kind of uh colon braces thing you
put it in there
um and then the style gets applied
um this is actually a style from my orgs
um uh you know where docx template that
we use or one of our docx templates that
we use and like I have no idea how to
make that pull quote in word I don't
want to know that sounds like a pain in
my butt
um so instead
um you know I used I leveraged someone
else who didn't know how to use that and
you know in my documents I can use this
feature
all right
this is uh cheating because it's not
really about words but it saved me so
much time over the course of my career
that like I just have to say it
um you should if you don't have one of
these at your org a minimal package to
sort of package up your design system is
super helpful
um so you can put all your
organization's colors into an easy to
access list this is going to save you
all that time looking up hexes and
remembering X's amazing
um and then just a minimal GG plot that
gets you most of the way if you have one
of these at your org like people will
love you
um you know I maintain the one at my
work now and people love me just for
that and I didn't even create it so this
is like something you should do and
it'll save you enough time that you can
spend more time focusing on writing and
polishing your writing
all right
my tip number three is sort of a general
life tip
um ask for help and partner up when you
can it really applies a lot with writing
writing is really hard writing is really
hard for analytical people because you
have like high expectations for your
audience you shouldn't have high
expectations for your audience and a
writer can help you with that right they
can help you lots of stuff they can help
you with grammar the grammar for
language
one laugh for my dad joke
um anyways
they can give you an outside opinion um
like does this make any sense at all
um and they can help you think about
your audience
[Applause]
[Music]